you probably already guessed from my
side part for endurance glasses and my
insistence and wearing black skinny
jeans in a tropical climate but I like
what my entertainment is a little bit
different a few months ago I decided to
make a video exploring hacking in video
games and I came across hack net and it
turned out to be one of the most
original and compelling games I'd have a
play with in the games world of
interconnected servers an IRC chat board
I found commentary on today's Internet
culture the musings of angsty teens in
the throes of puberty and real world
codes for hack net itself and it was all
pieced together with some of the most
compelling gameplay I've ever played
before I get started you can find that
hacking feature right here on GameSpot
on YouTube as well as all the other news
and videos that we are all making so
please subscribe if you like what we do
now I will be spoiling some major
mission mechanics for hack nets but I am
going to keep the story as vague as
possible so with that let's follow the
White Rabbit
[Music]
Magnum has a really simple premise
you've installed a new operating system
called the Hackney OS on booting you
receive a failsafe message from a hacker
named bit it's automatically sent in the
event of his untimely death the message
asks that you help find out what happens
a bit but after if you got a tutorial to
get you acquainted with things like the
terminal window and the net map you're
kind of free to do whatever you want
you'll quickly be recruited by a hacking
group called entropy that espouses
hacking for good but before too long
you're going to catch the eye of a
hacker called Naik's and that's when
hack net really kicks into gear
max hacked into your system and delete
everything the interface starts freaking
out and then all of a sudden your OS
crashes and your poodle back to a
command prompt I've never felt such a
genuine panic that I have in this moment
in hack net I managed to record some
command lines and navigate my way to my
logs folder and I found an IP address
that I didn't recognize I managed to
connect hack into the system and steal a
config file so that I could get my
operating system back up and running at
this point I could have just carried on
with what I was doing
finished more entropy can track and that
would have been that but I was pissed
off so I decided to get some
investigating done and I managed to
track Maggs back to his home system
after I found it I hacked in went
systematically through every single
folder stole anything I thought was
valuable and then deleted every single
file on his hard drive
well not all with them I left one log
that had my IP address front and center
now I know that makes me sound like a
psychopath but that's what's so great
about half net I was so absorbed in the
world that I just really wanted revenge
and the game never explicitly told me
that that was an option it just gave me
some tools and I could do what I wanted
with them but it does anticipate that's
something I'll do because I found out
much later that my actions had a very
major impact on the game story in the
recently released expansion hack net
labyrinth
you're always hacked again and you have
to achieve an objective in the real
world now when I say the real world I
don't mean the world of hack net I mean
the real world the world you inhabit
right now literally the game closes and
you can't progress until you go and
achieve something you need to do in your
own world it's bananas and that's what
the only time hack net infiltrates your
real world surroundings if you navigate
to your home computer in the net map and
type open CD tray your very real CD tray
will open on your PC if small touches
like this that helps tuck you into the
world the game developer Matt Tribbiani
has made every C
you hack has something for you to find
whether it be IRC chat logs archives
from the very-real Borg or it could be a
fictional email exchange between a
female sysadmin rebutting the advantage
of a male co-workers or files with
suspiciously familiar names for example
I just found a zip file called frog
fractions 3 beta zip and I spent
probably an hour trying to open it in
game to see if there was anything else
in there I mean it could very well end
up being part of a larger arg or just
another internet easter egg several
missions feature parodies of real-world
companies and websites as well as
obscure references to popular culture
for example one mission tasks you were
hacking into the tablet of a clandestine
government official who might be
stealing secret plans it becomes very
apparent very quickly that you're
actually hacking someone who's working
on the XCOM project and those plans are
after data retrofit alien probes for
certain adult uses elsewhere you'll be
hacking the web game neo pal no
copyright infringement in order to give
your user a million credit or defacing
the official nor an antivirus software
website which is the word x over and
over and over there's so much more to be
found in hack now but I don't want to
ruin it for you it's a game it's
constantly surprising and thrilling
quite an achievement when all you're
doing for it 7 our campaign is basically
reading and writing text but enough
about why I liked it I don't know what
you think
have you played hack net or are you
thinking about picking it up you can
tell me what you think below in the
comments you can find me on twitter at
git stand crowd or over on GameSpot I'm
always around and I'll see you guys next
time